o el presidente Daniel Ortega afirmó que
la embajadora neerlandesa para América
Central Christine anunció que su país no
financiará la construcción de un
hospital en Nicaragua fue este el motivo
de romper las relaciones diplomáticas o
qué pasaba ya antes entre Países Bajos y
Nicaragua
el problema particular no es con Países
Bajos en general también Ortega está
optando por una estrategia de
atrincheramiento en donde está rompiendo
cualquier tipo de vínculo con entidad o
país que le hable de democracia y este
el tricheramiento se está dando en
Centroamérica que es una región que
desafortunadamente cada vez es más
permeable a intolerante con el fenómeno
totalitario que existe en Nicaragua y
además por una serie de alianzas
particularmente con Rusia y china en
donde Daniel Ortega está apostando el
futuro económico de Nicaragua obviamente
esta rupturas tendrán terribles
consecuencias para para la economía de
nuestro país
tal vez el caso de la Unión Europea es
menos notorio porque solamente un 6% la
expresión de Nicaragua las que van en
Europa Pero y disculpa que lo mencione
el no aceptar ahorita al embajador de
Estados Unidos en Nicaragua pone rico el
tratado libre comercio y el 60% de una
transportaciones Van a Estados Unidos
esto contrasta con la exploración que
van a China y a Rusia que no alcanzan ni
siquiera un 1%. si habla de usted es
precisamente de la decisión de no
aceptar al nuevo embajador de Estados
Unidos precisamente este país respondió
diciendo que las decisiones de Nicaragua
aislan más al país centroamericano algo
que también usted ha destacado qué tan
conectado o no queda ahora a Nicaragua
en el plano diplomático
Nicaragua o mejor dicho la dictadura
ilegítima Daniel Ortega que usurpa el
poder a través de un colosal fraude
electoral solamente está dispuesta a
tener relaciones internacionales con
aquellas aquellos gobiernos que no
cuestionen el régimen de violación de
los Derechos Humanos que sufre mi país
por lo tanto se va a trincherar en
Centroamérica tiene el beneplácito de
algunos gobiernos de izquierda como el
de López Obrador y nexos con dictaduras
como la de Venezuela y Cuba y obviamente
Rusia donde
Nicaragua se ha convertido en tal vez su
Aliado más importante en Latinoamérica